hello and welcome to swipe coming up
tech stars of the future we meet the
university students trying to change the
world around us brain drain are we
losing too many young entrepreneurs to
overseas tech hubs
repair in the air
the futuristic aircraft that fixes
itself
and monsters ate my birthday cake that
and other ios games in our review
this week we're at imperial college
london where some of the world's
brightest engineering students have been
working on inventions which could one
day change our lives but is the uk the
right place for them to get their
careers off the ground once they
graduate i've been finding out
when muscle stimulating body wear is
among the projects showcased at a london
university you can be pretty sure you're
in the company of some very talented
individuals
oh
so bizarre and down
it's just like having pins and needles
there yes really intense
these students are innovators whose
engineering creations could one day
change the world around us it's no
surprise many from imperial college have
gone on to work for giants like apple lg
and sony after all promising young tech
talent is in high demand
but for britain to benefit most from its
rising tech stars it needs to be able to
hang on to them which is easier said
than done when places like silicon
valley are offering highly paid
internships
not all of these students though are
convinced by the bright lights of
success that could be waiting for them
in the us
i think the state is very um financially
driven and i think that somehow dilutes
people's ambitions and the core kind of
idea and the drive and the love behind
the project that they're doing it's
providing enhanced sensory information i
think we're now at a time where
it's probably okay to be based in london
and still be able to to collaborate with
companies in the us i mean you can meet
all of these participants in conferences
and connect up with them and
and then see what happens it seems these
guys want to remain where they trained
for now anyway but their tutors are all
too aware of a bigger picture one of the
key issues for a place like the united
kingdom and our major cities birmingham
and london and glasgow is can we compete
can we develop and run an enterprise
culture that is as dynamic as the san
francisco bay area one former uk student
who has been lured by the glittering
opportunities of silicon valley and is
earning more than 35 000 pounds as an
intern there told me there's more
support for startups in san francisco
here i
i think the the difference is that
you know you can try things you can fail
continuously until you hit the right
spot and people will not hold it against
you but back in britain where east
london's rapidly expanding tech city is
thriving investors even ones originally
from america say setting up a business
in silicon valley doesn't mean it'll
last forever for us we see that overall
is a net positive when people leave they
typically want to come back to europe at
some point and when they do they bring
back more knowledge and capital with
them people generally tend to come back
to where they're born i think every
immigrant including the two of us we're
both americans from the east coast at
some point in our lives we'll probably
like to go back home
so remember this face she could be
britain's answer to steve jobs one day
but whether her and her peers will still
be in britain by then remains to be seen
gemma morris sky news
well joining me now is ife and yay one
you're both recent graduates
congratulations you're officially now
inventors and designers are you going to
stay in the uk to begin your careers yes
of course i think london is really nice
place to start up for the young people
because it has a lot of potential such
as funding and market space and also
people to network with so i think it's
really helpful for the young startup but
i think for international students it's
kind of tricky to stay here because of
visual issues so uk government has a lot
of restrictions for further
like entertainer
okay and you're both international
students aren't you if you're from china
but do you want to remain in the uk yeah
i think definitely um even though i've
heard a lot of rumors saying that the
pay is a lot better over in the states
and for me specifically it's much easier
for me to get a us visa because i grew
up there
but i really do want to try to get a
place to and remain here in london just
to the fact that because all the people
i've met here in my five years studying
here are a lot more devoted and a lot
more passionate and truly in love with
with what they're doing so it's actually
easier for you to be in the states and
start working in the states but you'd
rather stay in the uk yes that's correct
and a really interesting trend that's
emerging is a lot of the startups are
basing themselves in london because you
have a much further market reach but
they're getting investment from the
state so what they're doing is they're
starting up their companies here in
london and then going over to the states
to pitch and then bring the money back
into london and develop their companies
here so is that something that britain
needs to work on then more investment
over here so then they wouldn't have to
go over to the states
i think definitely thank you
okay well best of luck with your futures
thanks for talking to me thank you thank
you very much
you're watching swipe coming up planes
that split into three how technology is
changing warfare
staying with next generation devices
here are a few bluetooth has been
showcasing this week including a way to
control 50 000 gadgets from one
smartphone
bluetooth isn't just about mobile
headsets anymore a new generation of
wireless technology is ready to
transform homes exercise medicine and
even farming
it's because bluetooth 4.0 lets smart
devices talk to each other using very
little power like these light bulbs from
the cambridge based company csr one app
can control tens of thousands of them at
once right down to changing the color of
each individual bulb and the technology
has even greater potential
using a mesh network technology like
this enables you to build some
intelligence into the network
that means when i walk into a room i can
turn the lights on if it's dark it can
set the heating to my desired
temperature and it could even turn on
the tv to my favorite channel
bluetooth's use of low power radio also
has energy saving benefits the lupo key
fob a sensor you can ring to find lost
valuables has a battery life of six
years but there are limitations to the
technology if lupo goes missing you can
only track it within 50 meters
it's not just keys you can monitor
fitness gadgets can link up to measure
your whole exercise regime but it might
not always be welcome polar's devices
get together to detect when you're not
pushing yourself hard enough and even
remind you when you haven't worked out
in a while
there's even more detailed health
measurement from cardio their brightly
coloured blood pressure monitors can
upload months of readings to the cloud
the results can automatically be
analyzed and sent to your doctor
potentially saving time and money
and health monitoring doesn't stop with
people the world cow bluetooth device is
swallowed by cattle to measure stomach
acidity thankfully there aren't plans
for a human equivalent just yet stuart
duggan sky news
you're watching swipe coming up wills
and harry host a google hangout that's
and more tech news
now what will planes look like in the
year 2040 some scientists predict they
could have energy beams which can
destroy missiles we've been finding out
more
it might look like a trailer for a big
budget video game but this transformer
plane could be the future of real-life
warfare
this week bae systems lifted the lid on
the technology they've been developing
including energy beams for destroying
missiles and vehicle parts that mend
themselves
they also showed off animations of 3d
printed drones designed to rescue people
but they're not the only people
developing warfare technology
samsung techwin developed a sentry robot
designed to operate in the demilitarized
zone between north and south korea it
was designed to spot suspicious activity
talk to intruders and even open fire
when asked to but many people are
concerned about drones and robots
replacing soldiers on the battlefield
one of the things that scares me most
about technological developments and i'm
a lover of technology i love autonomous
robots it's been my life's passion but
i'm really concerned about the military
use of autonomous weapons because they
have a sort of science fiction
conception at the moment we know that no
autonomous robot could comply with
international humanitarian law in terms
of being able to scrim to discriminate
between a civilian and a combatant
cutting edge technology has always
played a key role in warfare but the
influence today's developments will have
on future wars is unclear will sergeant
sky news
you're watching swipe coming up we take
a look at the latest ios games
but first here's a round up of anything
you might have missed over the past few
days
if you're a google glass wearer a new
app could mean you'll be able to take
photos using just the power of thought
mind reader uses a biosensor headset to
measure brainwaves and if you
concentrate hard enough glass takes a
photo of what you're looking at but
don't get too excited google hasn't
approved it yet so it won't be available
through the official glass app store
hello hi princess william and harry made
royal history this week by taking part
in a google hangout the pair appeared
via webcam live from buckingham palace
and spoke to five young people making a
difference in commonwealth countries
around the world
it was to launch the queen's young
leaders program well myself and william
are here just to show our support for
all the young leaders across the
commonwealth and you know especially you
guys and girls that have managed to get
online and stay online for this amount
of time so from from both of us a huge a
huge thank you for taking part in this
and um
yeah the stuff that you guys do is
hugely inspirational
dubai is building the world's first
temperature-controlled city it'll have a
shopping mall an indoor theme park and
even a network of temperature-controlled
promenades the gulf state can top 40
degrees in the summer so the move could
prove pretty popular with tourists
buzz aldrin the second man to set foot
on the moon thinks the first people to
land on mars should never return to
earth aldrin said this wasn't a suicide
mission but instead the beginning of a
permanent settlement on the red planet
elon musk who founded the commercial
space firm spacex has said he thinks
humans will start landing on mars within
a decade
it's hip to be square at least that's
what struggling smartphone maker
blackberry is hoping it's bringing out a
square phone called the passport
according to blackberry it's for
architects writers and medical staff and
will be able to fit 60 characters across
its screen instead of the standard 40
making it ideal for reading documents
apparently
now if you're into gaming on mobiles and
tablets you're in for a treat here's
holly nielsen with her pick of the
latest ios releases
thomas was alone
well
a weird first thought to have if it's a
platform of a lot of character you're
looking for then thomas was alone is
definitely one to look out for brought
from the pc version which was created
2010 that ios port works really well you
play as thomas or any other kind of
square and rectangle each with their own
complete different personality
and abilities and they have to help each
other to get through the level and
through the puzzle
it's a master class in
how characteristics can be shown without
relying on aesthetics each is just a
simple square of a color but because of
the brilliantly narrated dialogue which
is also very well written and it's
narrated by danny wallace
you feel like you really get to know
these little squares and you do really
get emotionally attached
was new
claire avoided them
it works really well um with touch
screen controls um i actually prefer it
uh to the computer controls just because
it's easier to select which character
you want
even for those who have played on pc
already the ios port is so well done and
the controls are really good really
clear and of course the story will want
to make you play over and over again i
would say there's for newcomers and for
people who've played it there's
something to draw them to it
vvvvvvvv not an easy name to say but
definitely worth playing although not
for beginners it is a very difficult
game it was notorious for it back when
it was brought on 2010 for the pc and
the touchscreen controls do make it that
little bit more difficult you play as
captain viridian whose spaceship has
crashed and you need to find all your
crew members who are scattered around
this world you control captain viridian
and instead of jumping you flip gravity
so captain meridian can only then flip
guarantee again once he is back on the
ground
this makes it very difficult
the satisfaction you get when you've
completed a difficult bit is like no
other so it's definitely worth it it
manages to balance frustration and kind
of joy
very well
leo's fortune was developed by 1337 and
sunrise llc it's a platformer but with
kind of physics puzzle elements to it as
well you play as leo who is a blue ball
of fluff with a mustache and a really
strong eastern european accent
i wonder how it works
i love that character
leo has lost his fortune as the name
would suggest and you go on a journey to
find out who stole it the controls work
really well the pacing of the game the
ipad touch controls aren't too fiddly
you always feel in control it's just a
beautiful looking game almost has a kind
of dickensian steam punky type feel and
also has really good replayability so
it's one that you'll be coming back to
the first thing that i'll really capture
you about monsters at my birthday cake
is the kind of gorgeous little cartoony
art style it's very cutesy but you
shouldn't be kind of taken in by that
because it actually does become a very
difficult puzzler
you play as nico who is a little boy and
monsters have eaten his birthday cake so
he goes across his island with the help
of three friendly monsters each of
different abilities to try and get back
the pieces of cake
at first the controls seem very slow you
have to touch and swipe to control where
they go and then double tap to interact
and it seems a bit cumbersome a little
bit slow at times but as the game
progresses it actually becomes less
noticeable as you kind of get into the
puzzles and it kind of starts to work
for it a bit more
that's it for this week don't forget you
can catch up with all the breaking tech
stories all week on our sky news for
ipad app our smartphone apps and
skynews.com see you next time bye